في توقيت نادر وتقى مقطع فيديو تساقطا
كثيفا للبرد في تبوك بعد هطول الامطار
الغزيره واظهر الفيديو الجبال التي تحولت
الى اللون الابيض بجده غربيه تبوك
[موسيقى]
وكانها ساحه حرب تداول رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مشاهد الاشتباكات عنيفه بين
الشرطه والمحتاجين في فرنسا استخدموا فيها
المقذوفات هو قنابل المولوتوب واحرقوا
سيارات الامن نشاهد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشهد يعلم معنى الانسانيه فقد انشغلت
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي خلال الساعات
الماضيه بمقطع فيديو اظهر عملا بطوليا قام
به عامل منجم في الكونغو الديمقراطيه وهو
يخاطر بحياته الانقاذ مجموعه من زملائه
بعد من هارت التربه عليهم اثناء عملهم
وثمرتهم نشاهد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جمعت ملايين الجنيهات من الناس وهربت
اعترافات صادمه لمتسوله مصريه انتشرت
مقاطعها على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
واشتهرت باسم المليونير المتسوله عقب
القاء القبض عليها بتهمه التسول في عدد من
مناطق القاهره المتهمه اعترفت بجمعها من
المواطنين سته ملايين جنيه اي ما يقارب من
195 الف دولار عن طريق النصب والتسوق
نتابع
فكرت اجيب فلوس منين فنزلت اشحت في الشارع
والمناطق الغنيه عشان اشحت من الناس
وبلبس النقاب عشان ما حدش يعرفني
الناس تفتكرني متدينه وبروح التجمع ومدينه
نصر واستعطف المواطنين واحكي حكايتي بصوت
عالي والناس كانت بتديني الفلوس
وانا بحكي حكايتي كنت بزعق عشان الم الناس
والفت نظرهم لي
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء